It’s a big day!
You just moved in with your boo and you’re
totally rocking this living-together thing.
But then comes the first rent bill and you’re
stuck wondering...how do we handle this?
If you asked your grandparents how they handled
finances back in their day, you might
be met with some weird looks.
After all, when they moved in together, they
were most likely already hitched and it was
just assumed that they’d immediately combine
every aspect of their separate lives.
The house, the Studebaker, Aunt Mildred’s
antique tea set...everything became family
property.
Including the bank accounts.
In 1960, 65% of children grew up in a household
where the mother was a homemaker and the father
was the breadwinner.
Today, only 22% of children grow up that way.
From a dramatic rise in women being the breadwinners
to falling marriage rates the relational and
economic landscape has changed dramatically.
These days, 25% of parents living with a child
are unmarried and 35% of unmarried parents
are cohabitating.
So the question is: should you consolidate
finances, and continue a time-honored tradition?
Or is maintaining financial autonomy more
important?
When we asked you on Twitter, 79% of you said
you combine all or some of your finances with
your partner.
And this tracks with national trends.
But this is changing.
Millenials that live together are now more
likely to keep separate finances than any
previous generation.
And it turns out there are some pretty compelling
advantages to keeping your finances separate
as a couple.
Americans with student loan debt carry an
average of over $32,000.
And the typical American is floating over
$6,000 in credit card debts.
With numbers like these, it’s easy to understand
why one partner might feel guilty burdening
the other with something that was “their
problem”.
Or perhaps you’ve been in or witnessed a
financially abusive relationship in the past.
Separate accounts can help protect you if
serious problems arise.
If you’ve ever known somebody that suffered
from a gambling or substance addiction, you
know first hand the financial devastation
that can follow.
But let’s be real - the main reason people
keep separate finances is to maintain their
independence!
In modern society, it’s completely normal
to enter your 30’s without ever sharing
your finances with anyone else.
As your lives begin to merge, it’s understandable
to feel protective about your autonomy.
You’ve never had somebody telling you what
you can and can’t buy before.
Why start now?
And if you don’t have to talk about it,
you don’t have to fight about it, right?
As attractive as it might be go “Lone Wolf”,
there are some good reasons the majority of
couples still combine finances.
So let’s look at what the “Shared Approach”
has going for it.
When money is shared, you can work efficiently
toward big goals like debt reduction.
Buying a home is easier when you have both
of your incomes and credit histories available
to work with.
And if you plan on spending retirement together,
pooling resources makes a lot of sense.
Think about it: is one of you gonna spend
your golden years in a nice condo and the
other in the tool shed?
Probably not.
Shared finances can also protect you against
unexpected pitfalls, like an injury or layoff.
And if you enter a tight season by choice--
such as taking time off to start a family
or navigate a career transition - anyone will
tell you what a game changer it is for somebody
to back you up financially.
Shared cooperation and transparency can also
result in a healthier, longer-lasting relationship.
A 2018 study found that 20% of relationships
that don’t share finances end because of
money problems…compared to only 4% of relationships
that do.
And a series of five university studies found
that couples who pool all their money are
happier in their relationships and less likely
to break up.
And don’t AT us with the correlation/causation
argument.
The researchers specifically noted that this
wasn’t merely a correlation but that the
“results demonstrate that method of account
management can.. influence relationship quality.”
So it’s pretty clear that how you handle
money actually affects your relationship.
There are also hybrid versions of the two.
Like the “Proportional Earnings Approach”
where each partner contributes the same percentage
of their income into a joint account.
Or “Bill Parsing”, where each person picks
certain bills and expenses to pay for, then
use Splitwise or Venmo to split large items
like rent.
Back to the big question: which is more
important?
The teamwork or autonomy?
We here at Two Cents believe you can have
BOTH if you work at it!
For example, we got hitched young, while still
in college.
Truthfully, there wasn’t much to pool, so
we went the traditional path by default.
But over the years, conflicts arose because
neither of us had much spending independence.
We hear this from couples all the time, and
it can really start to build resentment over
the years.
So our solution was to “have it both ways”:
we combined our finances, but we created individual,
equally-funded envelopes of “fun-money”
to spend or save however we saw fit.
So I get guilt-free thrift store runs.
And I don’t need permission to trick out
my mountain bike.
Boom!
Each relationship is unique and there is ultimately
no “one size fits all”.
But if you have decided to share a future
together and have healthy levels of trust
we encourage you to use your finances as a
way to work better as partners, while still
protecting individual freedom and independence.
And that’s our Two Cents!
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description to become a Two Cents patron!
Do you share finances? Why or why not? Share it with us in the comments.